I'm fine it's just that life is
pointless and nothing matters and I'm
always tired also I can't sleep I'm
overeating none of my old Hobbies
interest me
done nothing
wrong ever in my life I know this
and I love you ah
who hasn't had Gay Thoughts what I love
garbage jogging is the worst Chris
I mean I know it keeps you healthy but
God at what cost because we're smart
I'm dead oh Lord is he eating soup on a
bench alone
if I keep my body moving and my mind
occupied at all times I will avoid
falling into a bottomless pit of despair
everything hurts and I'm dying
somebody follow me I'm distraught I love
nothing oh so just because I can't go
out with him someone else can
wow okay
thank you alcohol
I am 100 certain that I am zero percent
sure of what I'm going to do I'm not
crying okay I'm allergic to jerks my
anxiety has kept me up for over 50 hours
no thinking just stupid how are you I'm
dying I want to throw up and kill myself
oh
buttery is my favorite food I'd work all
night if it meant nothing got done I
need to go lie down for 45 minutes no an
hour
a full hour I think we can agree that
all wine tastes the same and if you
spend more than five dollars on wine you
are very stupid no tragically we are
both heterosexual do you see the problem
here yes but I don't want to
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have I like
people
places
and things I regret nothing at the end
and I'll have the number eight that's a
party platter serves 12 people I know
what I'm about son I have no idea what
I'm doing but I know I'm doing it really
really well I feel great I ran 5K this
morning
really no I threw up in the shower
oh God did I Peak when I was 18.
thank you
I really needed this no I didn't win but
at least I didn't make any new
friendships although I've not worked
with you professionally as a private
citizen I have personally patronized
each and every one of your
establishments I've never seen you buy a
salad at Sea Salad it's because I don't
hate myself Tanya
I'm sorry I know I should be chasing
your vote but I stand behind my decision
to avoid salad and other disgusting
things and I think I have a lot of
support in the community for that
all due respect Miss lucky do you even
know what you're doing here all due
respect Mr hamster penis but no I don't
if I adopted 32 cats and dogs do you
want
me should be rewarded for not being
people I hate people
you know what I want pork rinds I want
jelly beans and I want a huge trash bag
filled with mashed potatoes I want to be
Pac-Man and instead of dots I want them
to be cinnamon buns I want to be a giant
head and a mouth and I just want to eat
rows and rows of junk food pellets and
where's my trash bag of potatoes
I'm gonna murder you I understand just
one sec as they walked down the hall
into the bridge stay frosty Wyatt we're
just getting started okay well that's
interesting you know why why because
Chris
I'm dying I was dying earlier today and
then I died
now I'm dead well it's actually not that
serious I just need you to stay calm
okay yeah I'm just gonna stay angry I
find that relaxes me I can't go because
I don't want to I don't want to seem
over dramatic but this is literally a
battle for April's soul I don't want to
seem over dramatic but I don't really
care what happens here everything is old
old things are dumb it's like just be
new I just want to joke until he passes
out what am I supposed to do he's my
boss no he's not he isn't God dang it I
cannot figure out who my boss is well
I hate doing work but I love being
flattered so
I see I tried to make ramen in the
coffee pot and I broke everything
cash money I'm Gonna Make It Rain
pick that up real quick
would you like any wine to start yes and
I'm gonna be direct and honest with you
I would like a glass of red wine and
I'll take the cheapest one you have
because I can't tell the difference
there's been a mistake you've
accidentally given me the food that my
food eats
what are you laughing because my dream
is dead
oh
yes oh my God that's so hot that was
horrible
I'm going to die I'm so tired
everything hurts running is impossible
my body is finely tuned like a microchip
and the flu is like a grain of sand it
could literally shut down the entire
system my body's like a chip too potato
chip
I enjoy government functions like I
enjoy getting kicked in the nuggets with
a steel toe boot but this hotel always
serves bacon wrapped shrimp
that's my number one favorite food
wrapped around my number three favorite
food I go to a banquet and honor those
Somali pirates if they serve bacon
wrapped shrimp excuse me
excuse me
there's a sign at Ramset Park that says
do not drink the sprinkler water so I
made some tea with it and now I have an
infection
sir
sir are are you are you listening to me
sir sir I'm talking to you
sir
sir are you aware
that there is waste in your water system
I gotta tell you Ron you were absolutely
and totally right I know stop talking
and get out yep
well I've never been one for meeting new
people or doing new things or eating new
types of food or traveling outside of
Southern Indiana I've had the same
haircut since 1978 and I've driven the
same car since 1991. I've used the same
wooden comb for three decades
I have one bowl the less I know about
other people's Affairs the happier I am
I'm not interested in caring about
people normally if given a choice
between doing something and nothing I
choose to do nothing thank you all for
being here let's get started
wow great attitude Ron
sorry I was talking to these ribs
run what in the devil's name is this
portobello mushrooms where's the Steak
oh there's no steak that's a healthier
option it's organically grown
okay can you get us a cold compress or
something
that's a good shoe shine